let's get right to it there's a lot to
discuss today from
teams that are playing well and teams
that aren't playing so well and one of
the things about teams that aren't
playing so well they they get a little
they get a little pressure get a little
frustration get a little stress a little
steam gets released from time to time
what you need to know this morning
begins in cleveland where baker mayfield
the browns quarterback
meeting with reporters on wednesday and
his wednesday press conferences are
i think informative they can be
entertaining they can be problematic as
it was on wednesday when baker mayfield
and tony grocery of espn cleveland got
into a little bit of a back and forth
originating from questions from grocery
about a perceived lack of urgency in the
two-minute drill that the browns were
trying to implement before half-time of
their eventual loss to the new england
patriots let's watch and listen to the
interaction between tony grossi and
baker mayfield from wednesday's press
conference here it is
it seemed like there was a lack of
urgency there or something going on
there was a penalty so we were a
negative yardage but there was a lot of
time between snaps uh well when the
penalty happened then we're behind the
chains no no stop saying but i just told
you the clock was running and we had a
penalty
you want to give them the ball back no
you don't play you don't know it
that's just plain and simple
was i happy with the drive no we didn't
score points that's the dumbest question
you could ask
what
jesus
and there's the walk off by baker
mayfield now he had spoken for a while
this wasn't one of those 45 seconds into
the press conference and the guy
disappears the transcript was lengthy he
had talked for 10 15 minutes at least
but the way it ended was a little clunky
to say the least there's a history there
chris between tony grossi baker mayfield
grocery was critical of mayfield before
the draft but
don't you at some point and i'm
struggling with this okay yeah i hear
you because i know that this this is who
baker mayfield is this is what you get
this is part of what makes him good he
he's feisty he has a chip on his
shoulder he searches for any and all
actual or perceived slights to fuel him
i get that the one thing i didn't like
about that interaction the whole you
don't play the game so you don't know
that is such a tired right there tired
and outdated and stupid thing to say and
it all it because tony gross has been
covering the nfl since years before
baker mayfield was even born yes he
knows the game yes it's an intelligent
point right lack of urgency in a
two-minute drill is an intelligent
question to ask so don't act like the
guy doesn't know because he doesn't put
on a helmet run out there so anyway i've
said enough again i don't know how to
feel about this yeah i didn't like it
but i'm not mad at baker mayfield
because that's who baker mayfield is i
don't want to make excuses for him but
that's who he is it is who he is you're
right about that i don't think there's
any you know question he's fiery i mean
he's feisty that is why we like him 100
now i'm with you i think the part that
bothered me the most is just jumping on
tony grossi there when you know okay if
he doesn't know the game then teach him
tell him give him the answer don't just
walk away i mean let him know now i
understand the point that was being made
there was you know cleveland had the
ball at the end of the first half right
they're down what was it at the time
17-7 maybe
i've i have forgotten it so but they're
down either way and they don't want to
punt the ball back to tom brady the new
england patriots and have them score to
end the half and then be down even
farther so that's the part that they're
arguing about but when you're a team
like this okay
struggling and of course baker
mayfield's not playing his best football
either uh
this is just not a good look and for
people who already think oh the
cleveland browns are they're rattled
they're immature they can't handle some
of these situations you know uh now
they're under the microscope and they're
starting to melt you're just giving
credence to those thoughts to where it's
really going to go under the microscope
even more and people are going to
continue to dissect every little thing
you say in your body language and that's
where baker mayfield's going to lose the
benefit of the doubt because you know to
a lot of people it's gonna look like oh
gosh baker mayfield's cracking here he's
cracking under the pressure and i don't
think that's the case at all i do think
it's just because he's feisty and mad
and wants to win but either way as we
know the perception can become reality
very quickly in the nfl and this kind of
opens the door for that kind of talk
right there
yeah i agree with you completely and
again i don't want to make excuses for
him i understand this is who he is
and it has served him well that's the
problem that attitude that chip on the
shoulder has served him well but from
time to time it creates awkward and
unfortunate moments like his interaction
with him and it was 17-7 i you know i
i doubted myself there for a second but
it was 17-7 the browns had the ball and
they got the penalty like you said and
they didn't want to punt it back so they
kind of moseyed along to let the clock
go down a little bit to kind of play
that in between okay maybe we get a
first down and go uh if we don't we
don't want to give them too much time to
get the ball back
and that would be a reasonable
explanation it is
there's that history there's some heat
there's some frustration i noticed in
reading last week's transcript from the
baker mayfield press conference that
that there was a moment where he and
tony grossi
mildly in comparison to yesterday but
but baker mayfield was giving it to tony
a little bit i understand he's going to
hold a grudge that's fine especially
guys at that age they're more likely to
hold a grudge and if holding a grudge
serves you well if it makes you
motivated it makes you focus it makes
you driven then so be it mayfield took
to twitter after he did the walk off and
he said this everybody wants to hear the
truth until they actually get it i am
who i am and always have been wait he's
going to be popeye for halloween don't
call it emotional when it's convenient
and then passion when it fits i care
about winning so yeah i'm frustrated if
i was to act like it's okay to lose then
you all would say that i've gotten
complacent my sense of urgency is an
all-time high and if i offend anybody
along the way
that's too bad you know i like that
better than i apologize to anyone who i
offended because no one ever means that
when i say it why not just say if i
offended anyone that's too bad deal with
it that's who baker mayfield is i'm not
saying it's right or wrong that's who he
is and it served him well i just thought
it was an unfortunate moment yesterday
and you're right chris it's one thing to
be that way if you're five and two right
if you're that way when you're two and
five it just adds to this perception
that everything is crumbling well i mean
i you know i get home last night and i
turn around you know sports channels and
want to hear just hey it's you know the
world series talk i would just want to
watch some sports stuff that's the
number one thing i hear on every channel
you go to oh and hey is he cracking
sounds like he might be cracking oh man
the pressure is it getting to them in
cleveland finally is baker mayfield
starting to feel the pressure for the
first time and i mean that was the talk
three different channels so there it is
he already started it with that but you
can be passionate and mad and everything
like that where this went overboard just
a little okay and again you know baker
mayfield makes some good points you
can't win always sometimes as a
professional athlete you take it too
easy everybody go oh damn he doesn't
want to win enough you get too mad and
passionate people oh he's crazy he's
flying off the handle but where this is
just a slightly different okay and i'm a
and i side with tony gross here
you can show passion and not be rude
still and that's where i think i don't
like it hey you know i don't you know
tony grossi and you have an issue
because grossie found out that you
wanted to be flown first class when you
were going around for draft visits which
in itself is so freaking insane that nfl
teams don't do that already is laughable
okay but that's where the history comes
from and at some point just squash it
hey you can be a little curt with them
and and not always give the greatest
answer and be charismatic with them but
don't be rude
and that's where i always kind of go
back to you know don't take it so
personal the guy's doing his job you can
be passionate and not be rude or a jerk
to a guy there there is a there is a
line there
i have noticed that the local reaction
to this has been to side with baker
mayfield and that typically happens if
if you're going to attack the star
player then as the reporter you're going
to get the the brunt of it from the fans
nationally though it's been more
he has yeah and anti-grossing right and
uh now and you know what maybe baker
mayfield you know he's gonna he's gonna
keep a list of everybody who says
something bad about him and that's gonna
fuel him and you know we're all gonna be
paying for it if we said something bad
about him over the course of the last 15
minutes although i don't think i don't
think we're saying i don't first of all
i don't care yeah i got to say what i
believe that's right and uh but but but
secondly i i don't think we're being
unfairly critical of him here i think
that we're looking at a situation that
wasn't his best moment yeah and we're
explaining why it wasn't his best moment
and how it could potentially cause
issues for him down the line yeah that's
right we like baker mayfield so there's
there's no doubt about it but you know
to your point with like the difference
between national and local you know the
one thing even on social media all i
looked at was some of the reactions
about this whole thing oh you're johnny
manziel 2.0 i can't tell you how many
times i saw that kind of stuff even in
the com some of the comments underneath
your articles uh on profootballtalk.com
you know just screaming through it
because yeah i like to skim through just
to kind of get a
feel for the heartbeat of the fan and
things like that and
it was all the same type of stuff so
again that's where you just got to be
careful because after a while the
perception will become reality and i
know you and i both like baker and his
passion and his competitiveness and all
of that but i just thought this kind of
borderlined on being rude more than
passionate
and look he's a young guy he's still
finding his way in the nfl these kids
get thrust into a high-profile big
spotlight and when you have that great
rookie season that defied expectations
and made you a guy who was on the verge
of becoming a short list franchise
quarterback that just created higher
expectations for 2019 and so far it
hasn't worked for the cleveland browns
now they've had a difficult schedule but
they haven't handled adversity well yet
how they handle things going forward is
going to be critical they have a game
they can win this weekend in denver then
they have the bills then it gets
interesting with the steelers twice in
three weeks and we're gonna learn a lot
about whether or not this browns team
can dig out of the hole that they found
themselves in but you're right the
perception at least for now is going to
be that they are cracking and if they
would lose in denver on sunday chris and
let me tell you yeah when when i when i
was doing my a but for but for the fact
that brandon allen is starting at
quarterback for the broncos i may have
picked the broncos to win the game if
they would lose that game on sunday then
it really is falling apart for the
cleveland browns yeah it's scary it
really is and hey the offense was never
like the thing we were scared of in
denver anyways it's about their defense
and
they'll make they're going to make life
hard on baker mayfield going into denver
and playing in that stadium is not easy
it's one of the better home field
advantages in all of the nfl uh and even
i'm with you i'm gonna pick the browns
but even with brandon allen at
quarterback i think they're gonna give
him a tough time and if they go there
and struggle and win or struggle and
somehow find a way to lose people are
gonna point back to this right here was
this a distraction you know is he still
cracking all of those things and that's
where it's unfortunate the browns have
talent gosh they just got to stop
shooting themselves in the foot in
football games and that just goes to the
maturity of them as players and their
coach trying to find their way right now
so i still have some hope that maybe
they can go on a run because what i see
on film is still a lot of good stuff
it's just when they have a bad play it's
tragically bad like three turnovers in a
row and they look up and they go oh
we're down 17 nothing in new england and
we haven't even broke a sweat yet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports